- L'archipel de la rivière des
Mille-îles, Huguette Larochelle
le contemple tous les jours.
Et se battre pour sa protection
n'est pas un long fleuve
tranquille.
HUGUETTE LAROCHELLE, présidente,
Sauvons nos trois grandes îles
- Parce qu'on a connu l'espoir
et le désespoir, parce qu'on
nous a fait des promesses
qu'on n'a pas tenues.
- La réserve faunique,
ce sanctuaire où l'on retrouve
les deux tiers des espèces de la
faune québécoise, pourrait voir
sa superficie multipliée par 20.
STÉPHANE BOYER, candidat à la
mairie de Laval, Mvt Lavallois
- On veut connecter tous ces
espaces-là, que ce soit des
berges, des îles, des terrains
à proximité de la rivière, pour
pouvoir les aménager, les mettre
en valeur, donc donner accès aux
citoyens, avoir des sentiers,
avoir des embarcations, avoir
peut-être des navettes
fluviales.
- Concrètement, ça veut donc
dire rendre accessibles toutes
les zones en vert sur cette
carte. On passerait
de 26 à 550 hectares.
C'est un projet qu'on accueille
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme.
- Un aussi grand parc naturel,
au milieu d'une métropole,
l'organisme Éco Nature y pense
depuis 12 ans.
ANAÏS BOUTIN, dir., protection
et conservation, Éco Nature
- On est ici en pleine zone
urbanisée. Donc, les pressions
sur les milieux naturels sont
immenses. On a beaucoup
de dégradations et de pertes
d'habitat.
- Huguette, elle, réfléchit
à l'impact réel que cela pourra
avoir sur son joyau.
- Qu'est-ce que ça peut changer?
Bien, il va falloir en prendre
soin parce que jusqu'à
maintenant, personne n'en prend
soin.
- Ça va nous permettre, entre
autres, d'avoir des sources
de financement additionnelles
pour avoir des garde-forestiers
qui vont protéger le site,
inspecter le site.
- L'année dernière, Laval
a acheté deux grandes îles,
mais il en reste encore
plusieurs et le candidat
de l'opposition a un plan.
MICHEL TROTTIER, candidat à la
mairie de Laval, Parti Laval
- Nous allons réserver
annuellement 10 % des surplus
de la Ville à un fonds vert
pour permettre des acquisitions.
- Il s'engage notamment
à acheter la majeure partie
de l'île Gagnon, où un projet
de centre de villégiature
a suscité beaucoup de grogne
l'année dernière.
Pour agrandir la réserve
faunique, c'est le ministère
des Forêts qui devra trancher.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, Laval.